hello and welcome to this video
this is a little bit loud the sound here
the board sound
so let's play cosek253
i went for the right yeah right time
control okay i'm going to try something
offbeat with a6
it's a pretty interesting line in the
queen's garment
it has been played a bit over
the last couple of years magnus has
played it
and some actually important games
there are some ideas um that i
maybe can explain
i have to think about this for a moment
because i don't know it really
that i can explain later i wonder about
queen b3 i know that
this is not a big issue of course
otherwise
this would have a problem i think they
play b5 even it looks a bit crazy but i
think b5
okay knight to d7
i think this i actually had on the board
once in a
classical time control game against a
strong german international master
oh interesting so what is he doing here
going for a quick f4 maybe
well it's it's possible okay maybe also
knight takes d7
okay i'm going to insert h6
if he takes on d7 now i can also take
the bishop
probably he will just play bishop no it
takes there
okay that did not look so scary to me
okay um probably with the knight
you might still have f4 yeah
just do it interesting okay so
what is the idea
i i would like to go c5 actually
i just wonder if queen a4 is
is hurting me queen a form
it's a bit slow it's a bit slow
my development
yeah come on let's play a more simple
approach
yeah of course that is something that
fits um with what he did earlier but i
think i'm fine
i just one thing i do wonder though is
it
maybe risky to castle kingside
yeah maybe he plays something like
queen f3 castle's queen side and yeah
you know
now i do it right or
yeah i don't think he can play he cannot
play g4
yet i think i can take on e5 take on g4
then
and f5 i don't think is so dangerous i
retreat the bishop and then
the knight on e5 becomes um yeah
unstable i can attack it then with queen
e7 and so on
so he just continues
um to build up which is
perfectly logical
and now i'm setting up the c5 move that
is the move that i wanted to play
um earlier and immediately
now i've lost a bit of time with that
but
when it um when we had the situation
some moves ago
i felt um it was not
well timed okay so g5 i can take and
play knight e4
i think
so i have to ready be ready for that
it's still going to be dangerous
[Music]
step out of this temp tempe
and he continues to prepare
whatever
this is what he's preparing okay
nice i'm probably just getting killed
him
also have absolutely no time
i can take h6 i think which is
just going to be too much
d5 is also hanging like i'm completely
falling apart
wow it doesn't happen so often that i'm
so utterly crushed like from the opening
it's just one straight line to getting
killed
if i can get rid of the queens of course
i'm still somewhat alive
uh maybe i'm still alive
remarkable maybe he
got irritated because of my time
situation
thinking like everything wins and uh
because of the time but that's not the
case
i'm still much worse for sure but
no maybe not
maybe not let me
check this one now i'm threatening to
take the pawn
take it ha equal material fantastic
d5 there's the check go here
f5
check
i think i needed to do it like that to
have him that he only has one pawn
connected pawns would have been terrible
this might still be awful but
it's at least
some kind of game i think i actually
played this badly i think i was
almost back in it and this is lost
it's okay i should have taken the pawn
of course
it would have been much tougher
yeah that was really bad particular
awful way i mean
i was back in it yeah like here i don't
think i should lose any more maybe
somewhere here
i'm actually a pawn down there which i
did not realize
okay then forget all what i said i was
actually not counting i was just so
happy that it was not getting mated
i'm just a pawn down i'm sorry that that
was totally
totally stupid yeah
now and i got totally crushed here
which was pretty awful
yeah i would have liked to play c5 in
one go but
this uh this always looks very dangerous
yeah probably i can just play b5 yeah
but
it still looks dangerous like c5 he
castles
and then let's say yeah then bishop d6
maybe um
it's a little bit more precise probably
but
i i don't think this should be
totally terrible
at the very beginning and then then it
got ugly
when i was not really
finding the right way to um generate
some play
engine wants to go b5 probably um
b5 and then bishop c8 for bishop b7
that's interesting to have the e4 square
yeah i did not find any clear
play i was just like trying to
centralize
and and hope that i'm not getting
getting hit too hard but i did not have
a real
plan for defense and this is of course
bad yeah that
it really looks difficult difficult to
play
this is kind of i have to make a move i
don't know what to do
kind of thing and this is this is kind
of the same
yeah it's really hard if you have like
12 seconds
and yeah i mean that's really really bad
it feels like you just hit with this
this wave of pawns and pieces storming
your
king side yeah clearly this is
not really great
and 95 here is killing me completely
instead of taking
yeah of course it does yeah
so bishop c
form
yeah and here rook g6 is mating me
basically
yeah i mean he did not kill me off
totally but the position is still awful
i i really totally did not realize that
i'm a pawn down in this position
which i should have this is why i
had this wave of optimism i thought it's
somehow
materially equal uh after i got h7 back
up but it was two pawns down and there's
that uh
yeah yeah tm
yeah you just toast to her right i rook
d5 is better
rook t5 i'm such a [ __ ]
it kind of failed wrong yeah what he did
but
this is what this is what was what's
this thing
oh man i'm such a clown
that would have been a totally
undeserved victory
but nevertheless yeah anyway i mean he's
certainly
deserved to win the game in some way
because i got outplayed
okay guys thanks for watching